hello i'm sam copeland and i'm a
national master on the content team here
at chess.com
i'm here today to show you an incredible
game between stockfish new
and leela chest zero in two prior videos
on this channel we looked at fantastic
victories from stockfish
new who was leading a 600 game
tournament between traditional stock
fish
stockfish new and leela chest zero
since then that tournament has concluded
and leela chess zero came from behind
to win the event in a narrow victory
the engines seem to be very very closely
matched although each engine has its own
specific strengths and weaknesses
today we're looking at one of lila
chessero's best victories
in the event a victory that showcases
its strengths and its ability to look
very very deeply into the future of a
position
this game begins with a sicilian defense
but unfortunately for those of us who
love bloodthirsty struggles
we won't get an open sicilian in this
case instead we have two knight c3
the closed sicilian which the engines
have been programmed to begin with
now the closed sicilian is going to lead
to a more slow and maneuvering type of
struggle
this seems to favor leela cheshire who
is better at deep understanding and
weaker at brute force calculation
stockfish new is not going to have a lot
of opportunities for brute force
calculation
in this game now leela cesiro has
brought this bishop out to g5 a classic
idea
going for the exchange of dark squared
bishops because
black's bishop on g5 is a classical bad
bishop restricted by the central pawns
and the bishop on c1
is a classical good bishop so stockfish
new is going to take the chance to
tickle this bishop with pawn to h4
pushing it back to h6 and now it will
induce
g6 with queen h5 g6 and the queen falls
back to d1 and after knight f6
knight on to f1 the knight is making a
nice journey to head into the d5 square
a key strong point for white in these
types of positions
now this has allowed the exchange of
dark squared bishops so we get bishop
takes c1
queen takes c1 and in this position
bishop
e6 now queen h6
this is a very interesting move when you
see the way that this game develops
the queen h6 infiltration is trying to
take advantage of the weakness of the
dark squares and the lack of a dark
squared bishop
it's obviously preventing kingside
castling
and it's hoping to tie down the rook and
the knight to the defense of the g7 and
h7 squares
on the other hand the queen can end up
offsides
on h6 now at this point in the game
that's not too much of a problem because
it seems like the queen
can always retreat at some point but
as the game develops retreat may be more
and more difficult so after queen h6 we
see
knight to h5 pawn to a4 queen d7
knight to e3 heading to that d5 square
castles
knight into d5 king b8 and pawn c3
now i think a classical perspective on
this position would say that white
should be
a lot better because white has good
control over this d5 outpost
and has kept black out of the d4 outpost
in return
however deeper understanding suggests
that actually the d5
outpost is difficult for white to make
use of it's very hard sometimes to know
whether an outpost is actually going to
bring tangible benefits in a position
and in this case it doesn't seem clear
that white is able to get
those tangible benefits so the rook
slides over to f8 and here we have our
first opportunity to capture on
h7 now basically throughout this game
it's never going to be good to capture
on h7 in this case the refutation is
obvious
after queen takes then rook h8
immediately traps the queen
so instead white decides to castle
queenside here and we get pawn to a6
and now the interesting move g4
this looks like it might even be winning
for white now if you capture here on g4
with the bishop the problem is
knight into b6 the queen is tickled and
she wants to continue defending this
bishop but she cannot
if she tries to attack this knight here
saying
okay if you capture over here then i'll
just take your knight on b6 and it's
fine
then the knight into d5 traps the queen
the two knights coordinate perfectly
so we cannot capture the pawn here on g4
but we can play the clever move knight
to f4 which of course had to be
anticipated
by leela in general engines are really
really good at anticipating things
especially
when those things are only a few moves
ahead so
in this position white can capture on f4
but
white will not get an advantage from
doing so if knight takes f4
pawn takes f4 queen takes f4 winning a
pawn
knight to e5 is a strong move black is
hitting g4
black is hitting a4 and black is also
hitting c4
there's no way in this position for
white to retain an advantage
if you trade here on e6 then recapturing
just opens up
more attacks and again black is going to
be able to easily gain the pawn back
and have much much better pieces in fact
black should probably be winning in this
position
so after the knight goes into f4
white decides to sink a knight into f6
in return
i think this is already a little bit of
a mistake from stockfish new
and maybe black is better at this point
leaving the knight here on f4 means that
it's very difficult for the queen to get
out of h6 we already anticipated this
problem a little bit
and it's becoming very very clear here
also the knight looks like it's
pressuring h7 but again
you're never going to be able to take on
h7 whether it's the knight
or the queen doing the capturing for
example after queen e7
if the knight captures here then rook h8
pins the knight
and you're not going to be able to get
out of that pin there's lots of ideas
including
f6 to try and go pick up that knight and
the knight will eventually be picked off
by black who can really take a lot of
time to do it if desired
so after queen e7 we see the move pawn
to g5 securing both the queen and the
knight in their outposts
but again these outposts are not where
these pieces should be and they don't
have
good roots back from here so now queen
c7
uh and in this position again we should
consider the capture on h7 but here you
have rook h8 queen g7
and the nice inclusion of bishop take c4
allows this knight to fall back to e6
trapping the queen so in this position
probably best is pawn to h5
trying to open the h file to get the
queen out of there
but even after you open the h file
you're going to need some time
to reintroduce the queen to the struggle
that can allow
lila to play aggressively with a trait
on c4 here
and then the move pawn to b5 it seems
like black is a lot better here and
there's good chances to crash through
on the queen side before this queen ever
gets out
but at least she would be able to get
out at some point in this game
instead king d2
i don't really understand this move here
from stockfish new
it doesn't seem to contribute to white's
goals in this position
and i think that it has to be a mistake
now leela continues with queen b6
pawn to b3 queen a5 which has an idea of
knight to d4
rook to a1 king to a7 here bishop d5
rook to b8 rook a to b1 in this position
both engines are really kind of
maneuvering a little bit uniquely here
and there are a lot of alternatives for
both engines
in these moves the queen falls back to
c7 bishop c4
queen back to d8 rook to g1 in this
position
knight c6 and now bishop to d5
this is a great moment to pause your
video and try to find
an aggressive idea for leela to
perfectly place
the black knights as is often the case
lila chess zero perfectly combines
tactics and strategy
with the tactics supporting the strategy
knight to d4 a beautiful and brilliant
night hop now you cannot capture this
knight because after pawn takes you have
queen a5
check the king moves over and then pawn
takes d4
black has many threats overwhelming
threats you're threatening to take this
knight
you've got the idea of queen c3 check
you've also got an open c
file where you can bring a rook either
before or after capturing on d5
together the threats are too much and
white is just busted in this position
so after knight d4 can you ignore the
knight
well yes but you've got threats to
defend against b3 is hit and after a
trade on d5 you could pick this off
and you've got an immediate fork threat
the only way to defend both of these is
rook to b1 now black is able to trade on
d5 and after knight f takes d5 you have
knight h5
queen h6 and knight e6 so the knight d4
move
actually led to a positional gain a
repositioning of the knights
so they have perfect control over f4
now in this position my weak stockfish
only evaluates the position as very very
slightly
better for black but actually i think
this position is
totally decisive the basic problem is in
the queen
how does the queen ever get off of the
h6 square
there is no way to do it this is
something that lila chassero excels at
it can see deeply into the nature of
positions
and see which pieces are bad not just
for a moment
but for eternity it does the same thing
with other types of advantages that have
long term characteristics including
spatial advantages
in many cases you'll see stockfish
evaluate a position
as totally equal or only slightly worse
and leela chessero is already saying you
can't resolve the problems in this
position
i think that this is a decisive
advantage and eventually
black will break through lila chess0 is
patient about that breakthrough
we see f3 here the knight hops into f4
king c2 rook g8 b4 here white is
actually trying to create an advantage
and initiative on the queen side c takes
rook takes queen c8
rook c4 queen d7 a5
rook to h8 knight b6 queen e6
rook h2 work b to d8 knight to d5 we get
a trade of knights here
rook c8 rook a4 queen e8
rook a3 rook c5 and c4
so we've seen a lot of maneuvering here
but the basic problem of the queen on h6
never having a route back into the
action has not been resolved
and in fact in this position black has a
forced wind though
you won't see it with a weak version of
stockfish
the winning move is queen to d8 here
now queen to d8 is threatening the pawn
on a5
so knight to b6 i encourage you to pause
your video
and try to find the brilliant
breakthrough that lilac chess zero has
here
this next move is all tactics the
brilliant breakthrough
pawn to d5 this move appears impossible
as the d5 square appears firmly in
white's control
but that control is illusory here you
cannot capture with the c
pawn because it is pinned if the knight
captures then
a5 falls and that allows black key
infiltration squares on the queen side
the remaining move is e takes d5 and
this is played in the game
the refutation is the very sneaky queen
d6
this move hits both undefended white
rooks
neither are attacked directly but both
are attacked indirectly
whichever rook you save there is a
discovery to hit the other rook
and to break through in the game it is
the h2 rook that is saved
rook h1 and this allows rook takes d5
knight takes and then queen takes
a3 this position is winning for black
some of the advantages that black has
include the exposed position of the
white king
usually this is decisive if a queen is
nearby to take advantage
the a5 pawn is also lost and most
importantly that queen on h6 the queen
that went to h6 on move 12
is still entombed now black's rook and
knight do have to stay where they are
for the time
being to keep the queen trapped but at
some point they could hop into the
action to give a fatal blow
while the white queen can never leave h6
in fact the rook and knight are able to
stay there because the black queen seems
to be able to win the game on her own
she picks off a5 and takes aim at the
other weaknesses
in white's camp and eventually it's time
to start pushing the pawns on the queen
side
so here we have some checks the b5 move
uh
advances on the queen side and pretty
soon we're going to have two pass pawns
over here c5 a5 and we continue to push
again the queen on h6 can do nothing and
she's going to stay on h6 until
eventually stockfish knew realizes
that she's useless and gives her up for
the night
of course this is basically engine
resignation but in this case the engines
play it out till checkmate
the pawns keep pushing forward on the
queen side and black will soon get
another queen it looks like it's going
to be a ladder mate
but white narrowly evades a ladder mate
by blocking with the knight
and allowing the king to run up the
board of course this is
a very small resource and now we have
mate here with queen to d3
and checkmate this is a beautiful
victory by leela chessero leela won many
excellent games in this tournament the
thing that she kept doing was outplaying
her opponents in positions where she had
small positional
edges positions with opposite colored
bishops
or strong knights or just one weak pawn
this was one of her finest victories
showcasing how the white queen which
seemed to be unappreciated
by stockfish new could be so out of
place on h6
if you want to check out some more
victories from this tournament some of
the brilliant victories from stockfish
new
then simply click on the videos that are
appearing in the pop-up
right now